all right why does it feel like it's
been a while
yeah is it for you yeah
no but it was the hotter we get yeah it
was a long way to go
yeah it does feeling along here well
welcome back everyone
ja ja ja ja sorry mother are you I'm
taking the work there they refuse to be
in the living room right now yeah I
didn't just get pregnant in a week
that's my dog I got pregnant too with a
ser Matt I walk there cam and he got
Selby ah he's then actually Sarah Ben
this episode of the Jenna and Julian
podcast is brought to you by me undies
me undies are some of the most
comfortable and good-looking underwear
you can buy they last long
we have some right here although this is
a new pair and I have currently wearing
a pair that I wear all the time because
they're freaking awesome this pattern
the idea I have mine right now kollene
saw them when you bend over one time she
was like oh I like Julian sundews like
that yeah those of me undies yeah she's
like honestly I do think yeah anyway
check it out me undies calm sloshed
Jenna Julian for your discount 20% off
of your me Indies that's Emmy undies
calm slash Jenna Julian ah this one this
lace one feel that lace sometimes it's
hard to find it's like solid way to yeah
Chi yeah but like sometimes it's hard to
find good lace on under Eric's then it
gets all messed up that's pretty good
place hey you know also that like my cat
oh the day of GLAAD was touch' gotcha
you're not you're on D sub me on D
they're definitely not peaches I wasn't
true she's a brat she is a brat she
loves stealing underwear uh-uh but today
we're not going to talk about underwear
we were gonna talk about fun or just in
general
celebrity encounters that we've had yeah
in our lives it's not very many you know
yeah I mean but just like those
memorable times in your life if you see
someone famous or you've had an
interaction with them what that was like
because I feel like everybody has like
maybe one or two
and stories and over the course of their
life like oh yeah did that happen and
you're like dude you why wouldn't you
tell us that tell us your stories yeah
so um after we finish the podcast or if
you in the comments or whatever you have
a celebrity story even if it's stupid or
whatever just write in the comments cuz
they're actually really fun to read
um pops up on occasion on reddit right
like tell us your celebrity stories yeah
every couple months that'll be on ass
credit but no they're really great sorry
yeah they're very interesting uh you
wanna start yeah sure um I think I
wanted to go sort of in chronological
order okay that's actually a good idea
mine are at least ya know that's a good
idea so I should do too um my first
story I guess so I grew up in upstate
New York and grew up in Rochester so
like basically you don't get to ever see
anybody famous ever everyone lives very
far away from you and most people have
the misconception that New York City is
close to Rochester but insides eight
hours away so he knows it's just like
we're close to Oregon right yeah it's
eight hours of driving away Boston is
six hours hmm but so I was there
visiting my aunt when I was like a
little little girl yeah
and she uh she lived in Manhattan and uh
we were at FAO Schwarz and I was sitting
on a big teddy bear in the floor cuz I
was just like in heaven I think I was
like 5 or that stores heaven if you're a
kid literally if you're an adult literal
heaven and I was just living and having
the greatest time and my I'm sitting on
big giant bear my mom goes hey Jenna
look there's Uncle Jesse and it was
[ __ ] John Stamos but I just like I
loved full house so much it would hit me
right in the giggle deck every [ __ ]
night or whatever it was on it felt like
every day and I just look at him I was
like hey is Jesse like I didn't really
at the time and get the appeal of seeing
the person in person you just thought it
was just them in character well you
could but also like I see them every you
know day on television so that's your
reasoning for not getting excite your
tonight
you see I remember like feeling excited
but like not that excited because like
who really cares same everyday yeah
that's really kid
that's like you really know the way that
you think about it this child logic yeah
like of course he's good child logic of
course he's a fao schwarz isn't everyone
Hagel Jessie yeah yes see you tonight
that's really funny yeah that was around
the time that I had no concept of the
fact that actors were actors I thought
he was like but that's actually an
innocent like mindset to have as a kid
and it's adorable to think that you know
that's Uncle Jesse that's Uncle Jesse
like there's no further construct of a
person who's working to make that money
who's pretending it's like that word
pretending that word acting isn't even
your mind yet you know it is yet yeah we
didn't like stop him or me or anything
we just like we waved from this big
giant I burn you like my back is good
that's awesome yeah he's just trying to
get some toys for some kids man she's
Uncle Jesse I imagine though if you're
on a show aimed at like families and
children though fao schwarz is a
relatively dangerous place to go if you
want to keep a low bruh yeah like you
know pee-wee Herman would get mom yes a
kid [ __ ] mom Oh mr. Rogers should be
all bad there spend all day in there FAO
Schwartz they filmed big enough we feel
Schwartz right yeah think so he's on the
keyboard Mickey when I was like I love
that when I was a kid faces alright my
first one like llama I have like a half
one cuz alright so you guys know Tom
Kenny in voice of Spongebob um I met him
a bunch of times because my dad was
friends with him but the first time I
hate when Jillian story stop start out
like that well my dad was community he
was committing that's life anyway uh but
I grew up in Southern California yes but
also I don't remember a lot of the times
I met
or hung out with them what I do remember
which is the story I'm gonna tell is for
one of my birthday's when I was a kid
probably like my 7 or 8th birthday
maybe maybe older I don't know um my dad
was I was like you know my dad's like
what do you want for your birthday and I
never knew the answer to that question I
was just like I don't know I knew what I
wanted year round but when my birthday
was there I was like I don't know what I
want so I was at Ottawa so my birthday
comes and there's like presents and
stuff and my dad he hands me this like
little present and I'm like well what
this is this is lame would you get me I
know the bigger the better yeah better
be the phase yeah it was like little so
he pulls it on it's a CD like a cd-rom
and I was like okay so he pops it in the
CD player which was a thing and and on
the stereo system starts to play a
message from SpongeBob telling me happy
birthday like a personalized hey Julien
happy birthday yeah it was like I was
like I was losing my mind because I like
like spongebob knows who I am
like this is amazing and it was like
it's probably like 45 seconds long just
totally personalized it was thinking he
was saying things about me I was like I
play baseball all this sorts of stuff
and yeah I'll always remember that that
was Tom Kenny and spongebob wishing me
happy birthday that is the sweetest
thing in the whole world yeah my dad was
great on my birthday he one time dressed
up as Batman on my birthday oh yeah he
was really really good with birthdays um
but yeah that was that was pretty cool
that is so cool it's cool even now yeah
I know
because not like it was a show that came
in with my god he's a legend still
alleged so edge is still relevant for
some reason yeah ya know very relevant
on the Internet
oh yeah and I love that movie I know I
know it's incredible
I love spongebob how always loves fun ah
ah
it is Gro right yeah that's so funny
yes that's my I think as my youngest my
youngest one one of my favorite finds is
that girl I forget where she is it would
it happened recently and she's like
standing like this covering her mouth
and she's just got her phone in front of
her Lee in selfie position yeah
the voice of Patrick and SpongeBob the
actual people are standing behind me
liquid sousaphone yeah I love Meghan
McCarthy I don't know I don't think so I
think it was a person a million [ __ ]
bajillion views on it because it's like
actual goals like Patrick and she yeah
there's literally like over her behind
her every move I've seen that listen and
she's just got she's not saying anything
just got her mouth her hand over her
mouth
oh it's like a fan she's just like can't
handle yeah I've seen that and it's so
magical yeah that's really good I love
the fact that like he's on vine now like
he made a vine with someone that went
viral like oh yes spongebob right she
was on TV before we have foam so again
you know I mean it's just nuts
so cool but that was a cool line that's
really awesome yeah yeah that was a good
birthday I'm not gonna lie I'm really
jealous don't worry I have a couple
stories coming up that will make you
very not jealous okay so my next story I
did not meet this person um but I've
lived in Rochester obviously you know
like the land of you'd see someone go on
a world tour and you're like well why
aren't they coming to Rochester like the
closest we could usually get might be
like Boston or Toronto if they went
there um but I used I was like maybe 15
or so and I babysat my next-door
neighbor who was much younger than me
obviously yeah but she was I don't know
I remember how she was little and the
movie Spy Kids had just come out and it
was starring Alexa Vega I think she was
you know between the ages of 12 and 15
maybe at the time and my little neighbor
Maria like I didn't know what she had
done this but she had handwritten the
letter to Alexa Vega and I went over to
babysit her cuz I'd babysit them for the
summer a couple summers was like the
best job ever um
because they live right next door and I
went over there and she was like Jana
Jana guess who wrote me a letter and I'm
like oh she's like Alexa Vega she got
the flag up but what are you talking
about like no that doesn't happen we
were you talking about an Alexa Vegas a
child okay what do you mean she's like
no look and she hands me this adorable
like in child hand right
or look at your teenagers handwriting
that it was just a letter that was like
hey Maria thanks for writing is Alexa
Vega I'm really glad that you like Spy
Kids and you know Maria had clearly
written her some stuff on her life and
she like wrote her this whole little
handwritten letter back and I just
remember like the blood running out of
my body like that was the coolest
[ __ ] thing I've ever seen in my life
I could not believe that she had
handwritten my [ __ ] neighbor back you
know what I mean and it just like it
stayed with me forever that like just
that like that much right there could
just mean so much to somebody yeah and
then it came full circle recently I was
really cool Alexa Vega followed me on
Twitter and so I tweeted her and I was
like hey dude [ __ ] thanks for
following me you hand wrote a letter to
my little neighbor and it like made her
entire life and just wanted to say thank
you and she was like oh my god that's
that's he that makes this story so much
cooler that it was like yeah it's like
how got to personally thank her yeah it
was like over [ __ ] ten years ago
raisi but it was just the coolest thing
ever
that is really cool I know I was getting
read really cool but like you know a lot
of people think that if I sit down spend
my time like writing to somebody or
doing something like you guys think if
you [ __ ] mail us pictures that we
won't get them where it's won't see em
or won't like them like it
something handwritten or tangible like
that is like it means the [ __ ] world
doesn't it yeah it definitely does
[ __ ] amazing
yeah that's what's really cool I like
that isn't it yeah yeah this is like a
feel Z podcast no some of them are bad
some of my bad yeah I mean I want to
hear the [ __ ] give us this [ __ ] well
I'll do two right now
um wait Jed you just like the worst one
ever
okay I'm gonna do it tell us um so my
dad uh was a baseball fan you know he's
a Red Sox fan and my mom was relatively
sameen she she was New Yorker susheela
Yankees and stuff but she wasn't his
hardcore she just enjoyed this part she
would watch baseball and my dad was a
big baseball fan and I don't know the
story of how they got it but my mom and
dad
this autographed baseball by ken griffey
jr. what like legends what yeah um I
don't know how they got but they got
like game used ball says ken griffey jr.
on it like legit like that thing is
prized piece anyway uh I was young I was
probably the same age as my spongebob
birthday and I actually remember doing
this but I was in the car and so was the
baseball uh and I'm in the little
backseat whatever and I find a pen and
I'm like this this writing is really
hard to read and it faded a little bit
it's in blue why wouldn't they write
better wait let me just and I traced
over the entire autograph like God in
black pen like over his bloop an
autograph and it's not sharpie this is
like ballpoint pen yeah I'm like huh Ken
yeah Jay are done there we go all done
and I was just like I fixed it you're
welcome no mom and she goes oh my [ __ ]
don't tell cat like oh my god what did
you just do oh you ruined this baseball
so fine she told my dad and my dad like
got mad and then laughed about it and uh
yeah I basically just figured that my
that's not even a celebrity counter with
a condition I know it just comes to mind
though I texted my mom she reminds me of
that but yeah that's not ridiculous that
like that's the way that you were
thinking though cuz that makes perfect
sense to what I was like faded I was
like that yeah mom's like have you seen
this is kangra feel secure but no one
can read it like what's a good so yeah
sorry sorry mom
so naughty god man that's right parents
please don't leave your children with
ballpoint pens and they have autographed
baseballs yeah ken griffey jr. that's
insane them um probably tell me next
sorry hmm this was so [ __ ]
embarrassing so um the comedian TJ
Miller
I am a huge fan of his I've been a fan
of his for a long time and he had like
reached out to me on Twitter it was
obviously more recent like within the
last few years a couple years yeah and
um he was like hey come be part of this
like kooky like web series thing that
I'm shooting I was like sure love to of
course obviously so I go there and Paul
Scheer the comedian is there and [ __ ]
everybody loves Paul Scheer
especially since like the league and all
that like when you see him more
frequently the role he really [ __ ]
gets me gets me going and the giggles
and so I was kind of nervous and I get
nervous fairly often I'm a nervous
person and I'm also very awkward and so
I was only in this thing for three
[ __ ] seconds you know they got like
one line yeah like a teacher was I think
just trying to be very nice to me
because I'm a big fan of his and um we
were I'm supposed to be like really
excited like next time like oh my god I
just got this guy's autograph was
basically my entire part and we had shot
it like a couple times and I was holding
a piece of paper as a prop that was like
it actually had some words on it was
supposed to be like my fake autograph
that I just got but I think it had pulse
lines on it and at we had shot a couple
times and I thought we were finished so
he went like this and so I cuz he had
said something to me I wasn't really
listening so I was blacking out so I was
kind of nervous so he goes like this let
go
and I just shake his hand I'm like oh
yeah it is really nice it was nice to
meet you and he's like no I wanted to
see that paper
Varis I was like oh my god I'm such a
[ __ ] idiot like I'm so sorry here's
it yeah like it matters like I can I see
that you're like nice to meet you it was
like the most awkward embarrassing like
Jenna II thing I've ever done and I'm
like oh I'm really sorry but then
there's no coming back from that you
mean like you once you've said nice to
meet you like it's very difficult to
then like hang out with them
you said the tone weird you said to
Congress oh so weird oh my god ah but TJ
Miller was very kind to let me be in it
for 30 seconds and just weird out the
place with my weird he seems like a good
guy he's very very genuine yeah I love I
love all the [ __ ] he does we're not when
I watched uh what's it called she's way
out of your league is that the man sad
she's out of my league
you love that I love that movie and I
felt like when I watched it nobody else
liked it like me and my brother watches
movie probably like 15 times the other
Richert was he farting no he's erupting
from my pregnant Kermit belly Oh Kermie
you born by ya weirdo I just felt like
that movie wasn't popular because it
maybe wasn't that popular but we just
loved it like I don't know I mean I
think it did well but ya know it wasn't
like a like a knocked-up it wasn't yeah
but me like as a kid I would always like
those movies that weren't the big ones
like I just like the weird shitty like
DVD movie just friends movies Ryan Ryan
and yes is literally why I'm busy
[ __ ] stupid dick dick that one's
[ __ ] I feel like for me that that's
one of those movies like why doesn't
everyone [ __ ] love this movie got it
yeah and my best friend's wedding but
that's neither here nor there that isn't
it oh yeah
that's on alright since that it was bad
enough that I'm like such a fan of TJ's
and he had like gone out of his way to
invite me and I was so nervous and
excited even just to meet TJ in persons
never like actually met you know so the
first day and then he weird it up
everybody's [ __ ] weird it all over
the place
Oh weird it all over the place but yeah
I just can't keep it together yeah
that's fine what's your next story I was
I was at with my step-brother and my
stepdad who were both Yankees fans so I
was default kind of in that clan as a
kid so we were at this Yankees angels
game Angel Stadium in Anaheim and my my
step-brother Josh was obsessed with he
and he's just as was my stepdad like
cheater and everyone they
so we watch the game I remember one we
we watch the game and then we leave but
I guess you know back whenever whatever
that was like 2002 or whatever they had
realized that you know there was a place
that you could stand where the players
came out of log right like it wasn't as
organizers now where they just go
through a tunnel to the bus there's a
walkway where I guess they walked out
and generally it wouldn't be the angels
players it would be the visiting teams
players so luckily for my crews like oh
the Yankees are gonna so we're waiting
and we're waiting and we're waiting and
we see a couple you know bench you know
bench players and bullpen catchers
walked out a little cool and then out of
[ __ ] nowhere Reggie Jackson walks out
like he just completely just casually
walks out this is mr. October he's a
legend Yankees right fielder I don't
know but yeah ISIL is they named him mr.
October and he's a halt I think he's a
hall-of-famer
anyway Reggie Jackson walks out of this
like doorway and me and Josh and my
stepdad are like what yeah right yeah
and I think Josh was the one my
step-brother who asked him was like mr.
Jackson can I please have an autograph
and we were like oh my god this is not
happening right now and he walks by us
and he goes no it just leaves and we
were like oh my god like what a
rollercoaster of emotion I thought no
one was coming out then it's Reggie
Jackson and then it's no one I know well
he probably couldn't he maybe wasn't
being rude at all you know maybe I've
always had this weird like vendetta
against him ever since that happened but
I was a kid so I don't know the
circumstances but yeah he could have
been like sorry or you know even said
nothing and I felt like it was returning
your faces hey no cuz I remember that
bar great right yeah they just left and
there was a group of people it wasn't
just us so and it wasn't like an
overwhelming group yeah yeah
so mr. October hates me hates you person
he doesn't hate you PQ um you in 2004
when the Red Sox won the on the World
Series the parade went right past my
dorm and I was sitting on my friend
shoulders and Jason Varitek Gainey's oh
yeah
yes and I was like wow it's like you
just threw me out of second base I was
like I'm out I'm out I'm like tapping I
kind of like let me ally that was I
can't breathe it's so exact pointy to me
I was like raining yeah Johnny Damon was
laying on the front of the float just
going like this I was insane to be there
yeah it was madness real quick if we
could take a short break
Tommy I need some me Andes all right so
thank you me I need you me Andes I'm
gonna give you guys a figure the figure
is 90% that's the amount of time in your
life you spend wearing undies
is it it is whoa okay that's a lot I
mean you weren't money's a lot of time I
mean I guess that subjects some people
might sleep anymore like if you're a
swimmer maybe less
I always swim in my undies especially my
Mia but Mia tees are great because well
first of all they don't like you know if
you're a guy they don't ride up like
underwear does that and I'm telling you
this from pure experience make sure you
wear them all the time all the time it
was a distinct print I wear what I know
and Julie is wearing his me undress
oh you guys can see a little bit I'm not
even lying I didn't mean that but I'm
very stop there varies they're so soft
but they're like they hold they don't
ride up which is great and it's just
like the freshest feeling of underwear
every time you put them on you know and
I've had underwear rip you've seen it
like way made that a snapchat the other
day for those wouldn't follow me on
snapchat and thank you for putting my
around snapchat but way before their due
date they ripped and I feel like me
unease is just made with this different
type of a build where it's like soft but
strong and it holds there's a lot of
really really cool designs ladies if you
want to see underwear they have a whole
new collection they just launched on me
a nice calm called all of me it's a
women's collection that it has a four
piece line designed specifically for the
female body also if you guys just want
to creep on the boy models wearing the
cool underwear you can also go to me in
these calm for that but and and another
thing is that they they you know the
plain black and then this design but
they have so many other designs like if
you like to jazz it up with your
underwear it's definitely a good place
to check it out also
uh if you guys don't like it you order a
pair you don't like it you're not
satisfied your pair is free they'll
refund you your amount but you can also
just get 20% off your first purchase 20%
off guys ah by going to me and these are
two percent micro modal and 8% elastane
yeah so that's like English no that's
like future talk but that's my gender
fitting stretchy
Kavya Bom Bom W bum bah how are you
bound on me undies Emme undies calm /
Jenna Julian I feel it likes the Mondays
so think about this you can get 20% off
your first pair of manatees and if you
don't like it you can get all of it back
so pretty sweet it's worth checking out
pretty soon thanks for supporting the
podcast thank you me undies now there is
a dogfight between Kermit and Peach
going on in the room you just let him
out really quick well this was Jenna's
idea she was like no look we should I
really wanted to be should have gone
inside the only room that we need to be
quiet for this entire hour and and it
was only a matter of seconds halfway
through their mom's day
well we can stay why don't you wanna
merely Mandy's that mobile you probably
were me undies here honey here he's like
trapped in my sure he's so helpless here
do you want to sit on the me on D sunny
alright so sad
that's enough fabric for mother to
decide be nice to sit on it trust me
yeah okay yeah good boy marble what do
you have to say let's see if he has
anything to say oh I'm still not ignored
Oh lovely such a little animal okay
didn't he go oh okay so I'm gonna go
back to back right now okay on the heels
of that really nasty experience play
baseball star experience yeah I'm gonna
go to a positive one okay so my brother
my real brother Marlon for red head that
you guys all seem to really love yeah
yeah he's like a ginger tunicate oh yeah
you guys
I love it well I understand he's a
good-looking guy anyway when we were
kids he absolutely idolized Nomar
Garciaparra and this was particularly
when he was on the Cubs so this was
after he had left Boston and no one
liked him and my brother was like I
[ __ ] like him I like I liked him on
the Sox but I liked it even more now
because he's doing his own thing he
loved all I know I know No More is a
really likeable player and he never did
anything wrong anyway
Marlon was that's it he was his guy he
was his guy whatever anyway so you know
my mom taught my brother and I sort of
how to draw we kind of just did it and
learn and my brother is a decent artist
and so he painted this no more picture
your mom's an artist my mom's an artist
mcgrann was an artist he runs in our
blood anyway he paints this picture of
Nomar I think he's batting and it's just
like it's cute you know it's like we
spend a lot of time on it it's paint
it's like acrylic or watercolor or
something on canvas like a like this big
it's like a you know size of like two
iPhone six-plus and he brings it to the
game which we had to bring through
security and we get there so [ __ ]
early because we're like when we were
kids we would get there early to see
batting practice everything so we're
just like standing over the edge because
we got seats you know when no one was
there looking you know trying to grab
balls and stuff and the Cubs are hidden
and no Marc takes his takes his swings
and then he goes out in the field to
start retrieving shagging balls and he
comes close to where we are and my
brother - yells no ma and no more looks
up because he's the away team right
we're in LA right he goes no more and no
more looks up and he goes I brought this
for you and he runs over no more runs
over and he comes over and says what's
up little man
and Marlon goes I made this for you and
he takes the painting and as he's taking
the painting no mores like thank you as
he's taking it the guy filming for the
jumbo screen films it and so everyone in
the stadium saw the painting that my
brother made from Omaha as he's giving
it to him I'm gonna cry this is the most
horrible thing and so no more takes you
guys thanks a lot man I really
appreciate and he runs right to the
dugout to put it away and
he goes back out to shag balls and my
brother was just like I can't believe it
it's like an elephant it's like a
one-in-a-billion not you brings the
painting to the game to hand a baseball
player a painting off so many times
you're not going to get seats right
there we're doing riding practice you're
not gonna get them anyway even yeah I'm
like seriously Kyle is it [ __ ]
adorable yeah oh my god yeah it was
really cute it was a cool moment for
sure gonna say he like jammed in his
pants like played the first inning with
it or something no I just I distinctly
remember him running right back to the
dugout well yeah they were so doing
batting practice
okay buddy I mean he came over sign to
kill the walls and he [ __ ] grabbed it
hmm he signed some balls yeah yeah yeah
cuz there was a couple people you know
my brother got his attentions I know
comes over oh yeah so you can say no to
a JIT sorry got cut off you ran out of
space at our memory card but I was
saying who can say no to a ginger child
with a painting in their hand and the
luscious ginger fro curls that he had
but really adorable yeah yeah that's
good sorry oh all right so what do you
got next um my next one happened like
recently um when it was like last year
two years one year one year ago yeah
when I got invited to the young
Hollywood Awards which is not something
that I've ever done before I've never
done before of yeah no I was
and like a complete fish-out-of-water
experience for me um just know I'd no
idea what the hell is that
yeah the culture of it is completely
foreign yeah none and um we have to go
down the red carpet or like what they
call a step in repeat or whatever and
I'm just like uh you know if I was
happening you know okay okay so you you
wrote wrong who works with us knows a
little bit more about it because she's
worked with musicians in the past and
like traditional entertainment industry
kind of thing so she it has a good
understanding of how things work there
sure and she's like explaining it to me
and Jillian I'm just like okay yeah but
like when can we go to Wendy's that's
what I'm pretty good we talked about the
entire we did personal yeah yeah and
then we actually went right so when you
get to the award show you like you drive
up you walk down a little barricaded
place or whatever and then you wait in
line at the red carpet of
step-and-repeat
and what some people didn't know I
didn't really know this because I ever
care to [ __ ] find out but at these
red carpets they sort of like shuffle
you like you're supposed to just kind of
wait in line and then the the actual red
carpet is like a like tunnel of hell
because it's like a relatively short
carpet yeah with like a background on
one side and then just like a bajillion
photographers on the other side and
people doing like press and video
whenever very daunting very disorienting
and all of them are yelling and
screaming
yeah there's no there's no inside voices
right which makes for a very common and
wonderful experience so um we're waiting
in line to go on the red carpet the
purple carpet the step-and-repeat
whatever and what I didn't know prior is
that you know they kind of try and like
shuffle important people like to the top
of the red carpet yeah so we're standing
there obviously like the young Hollywood
Awards was very gracious or like
wonderful and generous to bring some
Internet people and be like you give you
award I'd won an award which was
incredible but I think the the rest of
the culture was still very much like
Hollywood Hollywood
and so we're just standing there like
you know not not trying to do anything
except going flow man we're just here
having a good time feels like surreal to
be in a place like this anyways and they
are just like people's PR people like
these mousy little women are just like
pushing like Ashley Tisdale and Vanessa
hydrates like just pushing them up
they're like just get Bella Thorne later
they're just all like not waiting in
line just Zoop right to the front of the
red carpet so we had been standing there
for a really long time and I'm sort of
like do we have to do this like how we
just go in there no they kind of want
you to yeah like alright [ __ ] you okay
I'm good Wendy's huh but um so we got
budged I want to say for the better part
of like 45 minutes yeah I'm so I would
say close to an hour and um because I
don't have a PR person or someone that's
gonna go be like excuse me we've been
waiting in line no we're like no what if
we in line yeah yeah we kept getting cut
and waiting here's um and for the most
part nobody said anything to us it's
just how it works like you just go in
front and you know everybody else just
sort of weeds and that's totally fine
and no one said anything to us and no
one like really says they're sorry or
like you know says anything to the
person that they caught it's just sort
of like okay yeah um but Gina Rodriguez
who is the star of Jane the Virgin I
remember distinctly standing like I was
at the front of the line we're like at
the front you're like we've been waiting
for 45 minutes we're finally here we're
just gonna go walk down it make it weird
for like five minutes ten minutes and
then go into the show and she was like
the last person to cut me her PR person
you know gives me one of these and just
smashes me across the chest and Gina
Rodriguez looks at me and she was like
I'm really sorry about this this is kind
of like a weird messed up system and I'm
like aw so cam I've literally said to IO
like it's no problem like I'm in no rush
to get up there like no rush at all and
she like she like laughed and then she
looked up there and then she
she walked the carpet but I just thought
what a nice wonderful thing to do she's
like an up-and-coming star at the time
she hadn't won her Golden Globe or
whatever it was and she like took the
time to tell this like purple internet
space hooker that I'm sorry for cutting
you in line and I just really
appreciated that small amount of like
human decency at like such a vapid
non-human decent place yeah you know
what I mean yeah for sure and I just
thought that that was really really
wonderful and then I thought she's been
having great success and I think it has
to do a lot with the fact that she might
be a very nice person she you know it's
it's very interesting to see how people
treat you when you have nothing to give
them and you were just some maybe some
nobody to her maybe she recognized you
but maybe she didn't dad and you know
she didn't have to be nice to you know
she didn't have been completely
appropriate for that type of event to be
rude right and she chose to go out of
her way and to tell you hey I'm sorry
about that it just means the world
that's not the most exciting story ever
but I just wanted to share I think it's
really really meaningful when somebody
when somebody does something nice or
thoughtful like that I think that it's
nice for people to know that maybe that
person's like that may be a make you
think differently about he didn't like
her or that show or whatever absolutely
but I think she's spectacular and that
was very kind of her
I appreciate kindness kindness and I
made her laugh so I'm really proud of
myself as she looked fleek in person
okay it was fleas youthfully um all
right I think I got one more good run
okay um so we mentioned that my mom's an
artist in addition to doing traditional
like paintings she also did set work
when we were younger she worked on TV
shows painting on sets and movies and
one of the most notable TV shows he ever
worked on was heroes and if any of you
have ever watched Heroes there was a
painter hero on it named Simon and he
painted all these
murals and giant pings and she did a
better part of those paintings which is
a really cool thing there was like a big
bomb explosion one and she did that and
it was like on the back of the DVD and
we were like whoa
but anyway so one day I had a baseball
tournament near where my mom was working
on set and so after my baseball game
ended I came over to see her and it was
literally a scene where they had stacked
cardboard boxes like 20 feet high in the
air cuz someone was going to jump off a
building into the cardboard box it's
like that was there padding and it of
course works but it's just terrifying
right and I don't know there might be
some hero nerds out there who understand
and who can recognize what episode this
was but I see Hayden Panettiere he was a
cheerleader on the show hero she's the
indestructible or self-healing chillier
what did you use to hide your boner
though my god I just came for my
baseball game I was ready for that one
she was short by the way I was like in
action station I was like in eighth
grade now I was still taller than her
but anyway so um I was I came home like
can I meet her like she's you know oh I
want to meet her she's like oh yeah sure
so my mom because of course my mom
buddy-buddies with everyone yeah I was
like the most outgoing nice person
anyway she brings her over and she goes
hey in this my son Julian blah blah nice
to me and I look up and I'm like holy
[ __ ] because I like first of all my holy
[ __ ] is Hayden pins here second I'm like
your heads like missing cuz like
Thursday did a makeup job where the top
of her skull was just open has the dad
like lasered it off one of the years
like geez I think you guys would know
episode is if you watch a show and
anyway there's this line and then it's
just brain and I'm like Oh terrified I'm
awesome I get a pig I was like no yeah
well she was like give me a hug I was
like are you sure like I don't want to
[ __ ] up your brain doesn't yeah but
that's that was my experience being in
Paden pen here she was in full makeup
full like blood and everything and it
was between toes and she just like said
I mean is really nice um but yeah I just
remember half of her head wasn't there
when I met her that's incredible yeah
yeah it definitely makes it more of like
a vivid experience you know well yeah
damn yep sure is nice though shoes nice
to meet brains and all brains all brains
work you yeah that's nice it's cool
mm-hmm very mobile yeah that's pretty
much all I got was a really fun vodka
right I mean I'd like some more but not
really anything that's true crazy yeah
um or that I really want to retell yeah
some some things are better left not
told how are you um no this is yeah at a
time in a place you'll have the time to
tell those stories yeah sure
excuse you I'm sorry yeah the only last
one that I had I didn't [ __ ] meet the
person but his [ __ ] Dane Cook at the
Laugh Factory at that time he took us
comedy hostage yeah it was terrible and
then he got let go from the Laugh
Factory finally hmm but you know I had
tweeted that Dane Cook took the entire
audience for the AUSA's for like a
[ __ ] hour and just did the [ __ ]
terrible most miserable set yeah I hate
when I hate when that happens when they
just take advantage of people like that
I feel like people who look at Dane Cook
and see what he kind of comedy he hasn't
and here's something like that me like
I'm not surprised
mmm no not so well he's been doing it
for a while though to like yet literally
for those of you that don't know the
story or don't know what like what we're
talking about like it uh but the UM
what's the name of the place huggers yes
I the Laugh Factory in Los Angeles
I had actually paid to see TJ Miller
that night yeah Hollywood right yeah I
didn't I didn't know him but I'd like to
go see him stand up do stand up and like
Bobby Lee and some people so I paid
money I'm a paying customer you come
here to see a certain person or
comedians or whatever but it's often
that comedians that are bigger like
Chris Rock or somebody might drop by and
do a sense part of the appeal yeah of
the laughs factor is that you might see
a big comedian if you're just there I'm
Sheriff
and that comedians like to test out
their material and you know whatever and
so you know it's a go random weeknight
and I'm getting excited we're gonna see
TJ Miller and they go ladies gentlemen
very special guest Dane Cook is here and
I'm like oh okay you know not like the
biggest Dane Cook fan but like this
[ __ ] cool man that's ever happened to
me at the Laugh Factory yeah yeah that's
like I guess someone had come in and
surprised everybody
yeah and AH he just like spewed absolute
verbal garbage on everyone he literally
looked at a girl in the front row who
was on her phone like maybe after 10 min
he was funny for like 10 minutes 15
minutes and then for 45 minutes he went
down this disgusting like awful like
talking about how he wanted to murder
his ex-girlfriend or like that she would
get pregnant so he could like rip the
baby out of her body like just like he
wanted to find her he said he wanted to
find her body she like hung herself or
something and some person was on their
phone and the audience probably probably
honestly tweeting like Dan cooks at the
Laugh Factory right now and he looked at
her in the most aggressive like he kept
berating audience members but this one
was the worst when he was like I hope
you put your you better put you [ __ ]
phone away I can't wait till you die so
I can come to your funeral and text at
your funeral and not like in a joke way
this wasn't like a funny thing the
audience was not laughing Jesus man it
was very uncomfortable and he did that
for another 45 minutes and you know just
rape jokes galore and what a dick yeah
and so I had tweeted about it and then I
guess TJ Miller had tweeted about it
also and then Dane Cook the next day I
went on the Joe Rogan experience podcast
and they talked about it and Joseph
[ __ ] he's the man and they're friends
since forever and Dane sort of defended
it as like trying new materials my first
time on stage in like a year and I was
sort of like you know well maybe that's
just what I'm supposed to do as an
audience member like just sit there and
take it you like one person got up and
leave and he just [ __ ] like verbally
attacked them nothing
yeah and it's not funny anymore when
it's so horrifically negative you know
what it means
well I always get in comfortable yeah I
really can't describe like the tone and
that it wasn't like you know in insult
comic it wasn't like Colin Kane it
wasn't like everyone's laughing because
it's funny it's it was uncomfortable and
it was it was some sort of validation
when recently found out that Dane Cook
wasn't allowed to [ __ ] perform with
the laughs factor anymore for doing the
exact same thing good for just being an
absolute [ __ ] she deserves I think so
and I want my [ __ ] money back from
that night man more we felt was so mad
love I know but I'm just like sitting
there like we're all just in that
rolling when can we leave like this is
terrible
like I don't want to let it sounded like
somebody like in a therapists office
talking about how much they hated their
ex girl just like the nerve of like
being that rude to people just say well
yeah and anyways I don't want to end on
such a sour note
I was like oh no I don't want to tell it
no no you know what no I didn't like
that one bit and I don't think that you
should ever take advantage of your
audience's time you know any media
regardless of whether it's on the
internet or in person I think that
people are people and not nameless
faceless audience members and they
should be treated like people and that
you shouldn't be taken advantage of just
because somebody wants to try out
material absolutely no excuse you know
and I paid money to see TJ Miller and I
never got to see TJ Miller yeah and
Bobbie Lee well I wanted to laughs go
there to get sad sad factory sad factory
yeah well I mean not around the topic of
[ __ ] why don't you guys go get
yourself a pair of new underwear the
beauties calm Wow
the best-looking means are [ __ ]
they're just things that can cover your
a-hole there you go
some of the best underwear out there me
undies ME undies comm / Jenna Jillian to
get 20% off your new sexy sleek but
strong pair of underwear Thank You me
Andes for sponsoring the podcast guys go
check them out and thank you guys all
for hanging out with us yeah and leave
some stories in the comedies please
please cuz all I want to do tomorrow
morning is just sit and watch these
comments and read the comments please um
you guys are awesome thank you for
hanging out and we'll see you next week
for another podcast yeah bye guys
alright